bonjour madame la ministre merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité pour éviter
les queues matin et nice délégué chargé
de la citoyenneté en détention pendant
un peu plus de vingt minutes on
intervient en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
jefferson des sports de sud ouest
aujourd'hui faire ça bonjour orione
bonjour noir les chercheurs on va parler
mal n ya pas d'abord du pass vaccinale
puisque énième rebondissement hier
députés et sénateurs n'ont donc pas
réussi à trouver un accord un accord qui
ne semblait en passe d'être trouvée à un
moment dans la soirée et finalement
patatras pas d'accord ça retarde un peu
plus du coup l'entrée en vigueur du pass
vaccinale puisqu'il ya une nouvelle
navette dans les chambres parlementaires
qu'est-ce que comment vous l'avez vécu
cette absence d'accord est ce que vous
n'avez pas su convaincre est ce que
c'est un échec pour la majorité était
d'abord - tant que membre du
gouvernement je veux bien sûr respecter
la séparation des pouvoirs et le
dialogue qui se fait en cmp entre les
députés et les sénateurs
et c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des versions
différentes du texte voté entre
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat et je
crois avoir compris que les députés
notamment de la majorité ont trouvé que
le texte qui sortait du sénat était un
peu au rabais par rapport à leurs
propres exigences et que le sénat de son
côté n'a pas voulu faire les pas vers
l'assemblée nationale et donc il y aura
maintenant une discussion le sénat dit
qu'il a tendu la main et que là
je vous ai dit ce que disait chacun en
tant que membre du gouvernement et
dessous crois pas ministre de la santé
je veux pas rentrer davantage là dedans
mais c'est vrai que l'enjeu qu'est ce
que c'est au delà du texte au delà de
savoir qui du sénat ou de l'assemblée
remporte le plus d'amendements au
dispositif l'idée c'est la protection de
tous les français et faire en sorte que
ce pass vaccinale puisse rentrer en
vigueur pour faire en sorte et bien que
mon fils de plus en plus encore plus
être vaccinés je rappelle qu'en france
il a quand même une grande majorité de
français qui sont vaccinées je le dis
parce qu'on parle beaucoup des antilles
vague de ceux qui veulent pas etc on est
quand même un des pays dans lequel il ya
une meilleure couverture vaccinale j'ai
fait des déplacements diplomatiques dans
d'autres pays y compris en europe dans
lesquelles les gens sont beaucoup moins
vacciner donc je vais le dire ce que les
français qui nous regardent respecte
majoritairement ces mesures et c'est
important juste sur ce point marlène
schiappa la semaine dernière lorsque le
texte à l'assemblée nationale c'est jean
castex qui accuse les oppositions de
mener des coups politiques la situation
est quand même clairement illisible
qu'est ce que est ce que la politique on
sort pas un peu affaibli parce qu'il ya
quand même dans une urgence sanitaire et
que vous êtes les contaminations
continue de flamber oui moi j'avais
qu'il y avait un tweet de du sénateur
bruno retailleau qui avaient été postés
pendant la cmp avec des conclusion
partagée dans ce tweet alors que les
conclusions n'étaient pas celles qui
étaient en train d'être discuté en cmp
j'ai cru comprendre que les députés
voulaient qu'on respecte aussi leur leur
indépendance ce qu'on respecte aussi le
travail de la cmp et des personnes qui
étaient en cmp ce qui n'était pas le cas
de monsieur le sénateur bruno retailleau
d'après les éléments dont je dispose
mais bruno retailleau et les sénateurs
centristes également qu'ils disent qu
aucun prétexte de forme ne saurait
justifier la remise en cause d'un accord
sur le fond est ce que ce tweak il n'a
pas un peu servi de prétexte finalement
au député de la république en marge des
journées c'est pas moi c'est non
j'observe que c'est contraire à tous les
usages de tweets et pendant une cmp
puisque les discussions se poursuivent
et je sais que le sénat tient à ce qu'on
soit les sénateurs tiennent à ce qu'on
soit très respectueux des usages et ils
ont parfaitement raison d'y tenir jeu
crois que c'est le cas aussi des
sénateurs peut-être certains ne se sont
pas sentis respectée au delà de la forme
dans le fond de ce qu'ils proposaient
puisqu'il y avait là des conclusions qui
étaient partagés qui n'était pas encore
discuté c'est comme si on partageait un
verdict alors que le procès est encore
en cours un mot sur ce qu a déclaré
christian estrosi hier c'est le maire de
nice plutôt mâcon compatible 1 qui a dit
qu'il faudrait confiner les non-vaccinés
qu'il ne devrait pas avoir accès à
l'assurance chômage est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça pas du tout mais j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour christian
estrosi qui est un grand mère qui nous a
accueillis lundi à nice qui est très
engagé avec le présent la république
avec le miso l'intérieur gérald darmanin
et nous avons pu faire un travail
important ensemble mais je crois que
dans le débat public toutes les voix
sont bonnes à entendre monsieur estrosi
qui a été ministre auparavant qui a
exercé d'éminentes responsabilité qu'ils
veulent pousser le curseur un petit peu
plus loin surtout dans une ville comme
nice ou roux ya pas mal de personnes qui
sont vaccinées et qui demandent mon fils
est bien étendre un petit peu ses
obligations il ya trop loin c'est trop
loin pour vous ce qu'il a dit hier sa
rétro je veux pas le dire de cette
manière simplement je sais que c'est ce
qui a été fait par exemple au canada il
ya d'autres pays qui ont pris des
mesures un petit peu un petit peu de
jours comme cela moi je suis attaché au
droit commun c'est-à-dire que à chacun
et les mêmes droits
sansan différences en fonction de sa
situation sanitaire mais je comprends
que christian estrosi exprime aussi un
ras-le-bol d'un certain nombre
d'hôpitaux avec lesquelles il est en
contact et qui nous disent quand en
réanimation il ya beaucoup de personnes
qui ne sont pas vaccinés et qu'ils
cherchent les voies et moyens de pousser
chacun à se faire vacciner mais moi je
crois que le droit l'assurance chômage
on y cotisent rooney a le droit c'est un
droit toucher le chômage quand on a un
accident de la vie quand on est licencié
quand on a un problème et je pense que
ça doit se faire évidemment
indifféremment de la situation
personnelle de jean choffat il ne faut
pas trop emmerder les non-vaccinés c'est
ce que vous êtes ce matin écoutez je
n'aurai plus mignon non ce que je dis
c'est qu'il est important de trouver les
voies et moyens de faire en sorte qu'ils
aient de plus en plus de personnes
vaccinées et qu'on puisse aller faire
les personnes qui ne sont pas encore
vaccinés vous savez moi je distingue
l'escaut ce qu'on appelle les antilles
vax les personnes qui sont contre et qui
en font de la politique politicienne
monsieur philippot et d'autre d'une part
et d'autre part des personnes qui peut
être sont encore isolées vous savez moi
je suis paralysé mais d'origine corse
j'étais lui en sarthe je sais qu'il ya
des gens notamment dans des zones
rurales ou dans des villages qu'on n'a
pas encore atteint avec la vaccination
peut être qu'ils se posent des questions
de bonne foi qui sont pas anti vaccins
mais qui comprennent pas forcément la
manière dont ça fonctionne qui ont
besoin d'être rassurés et je pense que
ces personnes là il faut les rassurer du
coup c'est pas les les non-vaccinés
qu'il faut regarder c'est uniquement les
anti vaccins non c'est parce que je dis
ce que je dis c'est que c'est important
pour moi comment on est qu'on arrive
vraiment vers cette protection générale
et je comprends le ras-le-bol temps des
soignants que des personnes qui ont fait
énormément d'efforts et qui se disent
qu'elles sont encore encore perméable
face à ce virus parce que d'autres n'ont
pas fait ces efforts là après les
yvelines c'est à paris hier que la
justice a suspendu l'obligation du port
du mas en extérieur est ce que vous
redoutez un effet boule de neige qui met
à mal la stratégie du gouvernement non
d'abord moi je respecte décision de la
justice qui est indépendante par rapport
au gouvernement donc nous en prenons
acte il appartiendra au ministre de la
santé de dire s'ils souhaitent de fait
prendre d'autres mesures au palais je
crois avoir compris que la justice en
fait remet en cause le port du masque
indifférenciée en extérieur dans tous
les lieux et celle atteinte excessive et
disproportionnée à la liberté un peu
peut-être voilà peut-être pouvons-nous
et je soupe à des annonces c'est
vraiment du conditionnel mais j'imagine
que le ministre de la santé voudra
travailler à la possibilité d'avoir une
obligation du port du masque par exemple
dans les marchés dans les endroits dans
lesquels il ya une forte concentration
de personnes c'est vrai que porter le
masque quand on est tout seul en
promenade en forêt c'est pas forcément
nécessaire ceci étant à ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de forêts dans lesquels on peut
se promener seul dans paris je ne suis
pas absolument certaine on va parler de
la grève dans l'éducation nationale hier
oui parce que les enseignants ont défilé
contre jean michel blanquer sa politique
et notamment les cafouillages sur le
protocole sanitaire dans les écoles avec
ce qui s'est passé des annonces dans la
presse pour une mise en oeuvre dès le
lendemain matin ce qui est un problème
finalement très simplement avec jean
michel blanquer n'échappe pas au
gouvernement lâche pas ce qui s'est
passé extrêmement important nous avons
le premier ministre jean castex qui avec
le ministre de l'éducation jean michel
blanquer le ministre solidarité de la
santé olivier ferrand a reçu les
syndicats enseignants très longtemps
aujourd'hui on des voix là je les
entendais ce matin d'hier eux mêmes les
syndicats la réunion était très longue
il a fallu attendre trois heures pour
entendre jean michel blanquer il ya oui
et parce qu'elle est beaucoup de
beaucoup d'échangés en fait le premier
ministre tentant promise que les
ministres ont tenu vraiment avoir une
écoute je crois que ce qui est important
c'est que la confiance revienne les
annonces faites par le miso l'éducation
nationale je crois sont de nature à
rassurer tant sur la distribution par
exemple des masques ffp2 pour des
personnels de l'éducation nationale ce
qui était demandé sur les recrutements
pour les assistants d'éducation et pour
aider les directeurs et directrices
d'école sur des tâches administratives
qui sont très difficiles et qui sont
chronophages en cette période de
pandémie mais également sur l'abondement
du fonds pour les purificateurs pour
aller ailleurs d'anticipation alors
c'est toujours facile à postériori
pourtant c'est ce que les oppositions
vous reproche depuis de longs mois c'est
ce manque d'anticipation prévisions sur
la gestion de la crise sanitaire non moi
je crois que la situation elle est
difficile dans la mesure où le miz
l'éducation nationale avec l'ensemble du
gouvernement et avec le président la
république nous avons décidé de prendre
une décision qui est une décision
courageuse qui est de maintenir les
écoles ouvertes moi j'y suis très
attaché pourquoi d'abord parce que vous
avez beaucoup d'enfants qui sont dans
des familles en situation de précarité
je suis qui n'ont pas à manger s'il ne
mange pas à la cantine le midi d'une
part d'autre part vous avez des
situations de violence intrafamiliale au
sexe est un combat que je porte et nous
avons eu pendant le fonctionnement des
enfants qui se retrouve enfermé seul
avec leurs bourreaux toute la journée
sans possibilité de signalements sont
soupape de décompression
c'est est gravissime et puis la question
des apprentissages quand même on va à
l'école aussi pour apprendre et donc je
crois que c'est important que l'école
reste ou pas ça ne se fait pas sans
difficulté c'est vrai ça ne se fait pas
sans fatiguer pour les enseignants et je
la comprends parfaitement jeu du nom
d'un green de renoir je conjure remettre
à la molière vous comprenez lorsque nos
mais je voulais quand la fatigue je
comprends la lassitude je comprends
aussi celle des parents chf mère d'élève
moi même je partage avec mes camarades
parlant délai si je me le dire de cette
manière est évident le il ya un
protocole il ya des tests à faire nos
enfants sont qu'à contacter quasiment
tous les jours mais je crois que il faut
pas prendre le miz l'éducation nationale
comme comme bouc émissaire de la
situation nous combattons ensemble un
virus et je pense que c'est important de
le faire ensemble et donc moi je me
réjouis que les syndicats d'enseignants
étaient été reçus entendu et qu'il y ait
des gens qui aillent dans la hausse il a
fallu cette grève il faut attendre deux
ans pour créer une instance de dialogue
et d'écouté d'information c'est ce qu'a
dit hier jean michel blanquer bimensuel
il faut attendre deux ans pour
distribuer des masques ffp2 est ce que
vous comprenez que les enseignants
neymar oui mais c'est vrai qu'on peut
toujours s'améliorer et heureusement
qu'il ya des décisions qui sont prises
et que ce mouvement est entendu certains
vraiment dans l' écoute et le fait que
le premier ministre lui-même et souhaité
présider cette réunion cet échange nous
montre jean castex savez maintenant j'ai
appris à les connaître depuis presque
deux ans c'est profondément un homme d'
écoute c'est un homme son joueur à moins
de 100 jours du premier film et c'est
son style urgence et un incendie n'ont
cessé ça c'est sa manière de gouverner
j'ai appris à le connaître mais le
premier c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui est
très attaché à l' écoute beaucoup de
déplacements avec free notamment près
dès hôpitaux mais dans des commissariats
il aime toujours écouter discuter
trouver des solutions et avec le
ministre de la santé et mise de
l'éducation nationale qui sont chacun
experts dans leur domaine et qui ont
voulu apporter des réponses je crois que
des solutions début de solution en tout
cas ont été partagés laisse ainsi avec
le politique guettait avait un risque
politique pour emmanuel mâcon de cette
fronde des enseignants je suis pas sûr
que ce soit ça qui procède des décisions
je pense que c'est avant tout une écoute
de la situation et la volonté vraiment
trouver des solutions les personnes
lançaient les personnels enseignants
réclament et des masques ffp2 depuis un
moment le miz de l'éducation nationale a
décidé de les en temps de les mettre à
disposition c'est une bonne chose la
crise sanitaire et le pass and i ter et
le pass vaccinale ont fait monter encore
un cran les violences envers les élus
ans c'est un dossier que vous suivez
bien évident 300 plaintes déposées
depuis juillet c'est ce qu'a dit
ministère de l'intérieur 1186 élus ont
été pris pour cible en 2021 162
parlementaire et 605 mer parmi ces élus
est-ce qu'il faut prendre des mesures
supplémentaires pour les protéger oui
toujours et nous en avons crise au delà
de la loi qui a renforcé notamment la
possibilité de former les élus avec les
forces de l'ordre notamment le gign
échanges avec les élus pour les formes
juste sous la peau david lisnard il
était devant le sénat hier le président
de l'association des maires de france et
il a dit quand un maire ou sur une
formation du gign ça veut dire que le
pays ne va pas très bien vous partagez
cette phrase oui écouter évidemment moi
je crois que la violence elle et elle
est de plus en plus grave les menaces
face aux élus des menaces face et à des
journalistes moi je change régulièrement
avec des journalistes qui me disait à
quel point ils et elles sont menacées
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux dès
lors qu'ils s'expriment dé laure king
heen où elle particulièrement prennent
la parole les menaces contre les
enseignants des violences également
contre les soignants comme on a vu en
guadeloupe les actes antireligieux
j'étais hier avec les deux
parlementaires qui sont en mission
monsieur mendes et madame florennes qui
sont en mission sur les actes
antireligieux
eh bien on voit à quel point il ya des
gens qui décident d'aller profané des
cimetières d'aller saccager des églises
ou des synagogues ou des mosquées
effectivement cette violence dans la
société elle est préoccupante regardez
le fait contre lequel
les forces de l'ordre se sont mobilisés
cet homme qui traînait dans la rue des
personnes je pense que vous avez vu
cette actualité à quel niveau de cruauté
en est on arrivé ça qu'on n'est même
plus sûr le fait de violences est à dire
la colère et la violence parce qu'on
n'arrive pas à exprimer sa colère
autrement que dans la violence on est
sûr de la cruauté prémédité et sur un
acte vraiment de cruauté et de barbarie
et moi en étant au ministère de
l'intérieur je vois des actes de la
sorte je pense que c'est absolument
important que nous avons une
responsabilité pour apaiser justement le
débat pour faire en sorte que ces
violences n'existe pas de dire que le
débat oui la controverse oui bien sûr
mais la violence la menace l'insultent
non mais du coup effectivement vous avez
pris des mesures absolument durement
mais est ce que au vu de ce qui se passe
et de l'augmentation de ces violences
ces mesures sont
insuffisante comment vous y en avoir
d'autres en fait on a pris des mesures
qui sont de l'ordre de l'ordre qui sont
législatives nous avons pris des mesures
qui sont des circulaires avec notamment
la volonté d'une réponse pénale ferme et
rapide sur ces sujets nous avons
l'impression que ça suffit puisque vous
malheur on a appris aussi d'autres qui
sont très récentes le ministre de
l'intérieur extrêmement mobilisés sur ce
sujet et gérald darmanin a demandé aux
préfets de faire en sorte que dans
toutes les rondes des forces de l'ordre
on puisse aussi un furent les domiciles
et les permanences des parlementaires
c'est extrêmement important sauf que les
forces de l'ordre sont mobilisés pour la
protection des parlementaires des élus
qui serait menacé c'est normal et le
ministre de l'intérieur suit de très
près ce sujet là il reçoit également le
garde des sceaux et président de
l'assemblée nationale richard ferrand
qui a souhaité comme me semble-t-il
gérard larcher d'ailleurs présente du
sénat se porter partie civile dès lors
qu'il y aurait une plainte d'un
parlementaire je trouve que c'est un
beau message un beau symbole d'unité de
l'année c'est ce que demandait hier
également david né snark l'association
des maires de france puissent se porter
partie civile ça veut dire vous êtes
favorable à ça parce que ça fait moi je
crois que c'est important car ce beau
message d'unité et de dire que voilà
c'est pas les uns contre les autres et
que aucun élu de nulle part ne cautionne
des violences face à ses adversaires
politiques c'est facile de soutenir des
gens qui sont dans notre parti politique
je demande qu'on soutienne aussi ceux
qui sont dans l'opposition moi je les
fais quand madame le pen était menacé je
les ai soutenus quand la conseillère
d'eric zemmour était harcelé gelé
soutenu je pense que c'est contre raquel
garrido avec 6 corbières de la france
insoumise ont été menacés sur les
réseaux sociaux je les ai également
soutenu je pense que c'est important
c'est pas une vision personnes
suggestion de principe de soutenir tous
les îles mais ce cas pas aussi un
problème dans le chai vielles judiciaire
est ce qu a pas trop de classement sans
suite de ces plaintes d'abus mais c'est
vrai que la difficulté c'est qu'il faut
pouvoir les caractériser et j'en sais
quelque chose étant largement menacés
moi même et je dépose régulièrement via
mon avocate des plaintes et c'est vrai
qu'il fait aboutir ça dépend certaines
n'aboutissent pas certaines sont longues
et sont encore en cours de traitement et
puis d'autres aboutisse il ya eu des
condamnations et je peux vous dire
d'ailleurs que notamment pour ce qui
concerne les réseaux sociaux en général
on retrouve des gens qui sont dans leurs
petits souliers qui nous disent je
n'avais pas conscience de ce que je
faisais c'était pas contre vous je
m'ennuyais c'était pour m'occuper les
les argumentaires qu'on peut entendre
lors des procès sont sont assez lunaire
en fait pour soudeur et ça pose la
question de l'anonymat également ça
repose la question de l'anonymat sur sa
pose la question de la coopération des
réseaux sociaux vous savez nous avons
augmenté les moyens de pharos c'est le
président la république qui a voulu
faire en sorte que fait pressante de
signalements exact un signalement de la
nbi soient ouverts désormais vingt
quatre heures sur vingt gardes c'est
important avant pharos et dès 9h 17h 9h
18h c'est aujourd'hui vingt quatre
heures sur 24 nous avons ni des emplois
en plus il faut maintenant que les
réseaux sociaux contribuent bien
davantage pour retirer les contenus et
pour être aussi proactif c'est pas à
l'état de faire la modération
bénévolement des réseaux sociaux n'est
pas parce que vous craignez que cette
montée des violences contre les hélices
ou attachés à ce quinquennat vous avez
un président de la république
aujourd'hui qui assume de cliver au
début du quinquennat on parlait plutôt
d'une communication disruptif disruptive
c'était un peu moins de cash là on sent
que là aussi d'une forme de radicalité
dans l'expression je sais pas vous savez
moi je me souviens des années de la
présidence de nicolas sarkozy où il y
avait beaucoup d'expressions de caching
y compris non je veux dire de la
population qui met expressions de rejet
vis-à-vis de son présent la république
je me souviens de la présidence de
françois hollande qui est arrivé à un
tel niveau détestation dans son propre
camp qui n'a même pas pu se représenter
je crois qu'il était à 4% de confiance
de la part des citoyens à la fin de son
quinquennat c'est pas du tout le cas
d'emmanuel macro emmanuel macron attire
la conscience je crois qu'il est plutôt
soutenu c'est en tout cas ce que disent
les études d'opinion moi je me déplace
souvent avec le président la république
l'immense majorité des personnes qui
l'accueille l'accueille favorablement
soit les du soutien sont en tout cas
avec le respect dû à la fonction du
président la république qui nous
représente tous se posent la question
maintenant de la campagne présidentielle
qui va se faire sous coville il ya très
peu de suspense il ya une première
réunion du comité de liaison
duco vide qui se tient ce matin avec les
représentants des partis politiques les
représentants des candidats à la
présidentielle et un premier point qui a
été fait mardi est-ce qui aura là aussi
de nouvelles mesures qui seront mises en
place pour assurer cette présidentielle
socogib là aussi c'est extrêmement
important pour nous d'écouter et de
faire en sorte qu' une responsabilité
collective et partagée c'est à dire que
je rappelle je sais que ceux qui
regardent public sénat sont aguerris
sont au fait du processus parlementaire
mais je rappelle qu'il y à une loi comme
chaque quinquennat qui a déjà été votée
je représentais les gouvernements au
banc à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
c'est une loi qui vise à organiser les
élections présidentielles donc les
grandes modalités d'organisation de
l'élection présidentielle ont d'ores et
déjà été votée maintenant il ya des
sujets sur lesquels nous pouvons avancer
nous au ministère de l'intérieur par
exemple nous avons développé ma
procuration point fr qui permet d'avoir
une préparation très rapide de la
procuration nous avons fait de nouvelle
carte électorale avec des qr code qui
permet de savoir immédiatement si vous
êtes oui ou non inscrits sur les listes
électorales dans quel bureau de vote à
quelle date se passe les élections et
c'est pour nous adresser aux jeunes et
ce malgré la pandémie j'ai créé une task
force avec l'ensemble des plateformes
twitter facebook tictoc instagram
snapshot etc etc et nous leur avons
demandé de communiquer sur les réseaux
sociaux en direction des personnes de
leurs utilisateurs des personnes qui
sont inscrites avec les dates des
élections les candidats vers des accès
aux sites dans lesquels on peut
consulter les programmes etc je pense
que tout sujet par les sallois parmi les
demandes des partis politiques et à les
questions des procurations pour évoquer
notamment de la double procuration qui
ne figure pas dans la loi a été votée
dont vous parlez est ce que ça vous
pouvez le changer dans le temps
parlementaire qu'il reste est ce que
vous avez envie de le changer à ce que
la double procuration peut être mises en
place par la double procuration l'avait
mise en place de façon tout à fait
exceptionnelle pour les précédentes
élections locales justement du fait de
la pandémie parce que nous sortions à
l'époque du tout juste d'un confinement
nous étions dans une période extrêmement
difficile et les parlementaires c'est
par mois les parlementaires ont voté à
l'unanimité les parlementaires ont
souhaité ne pas reconduire la double
procuration en revanche a été votée la
déterritorialisation de la procuration
qui permet de donner une procuration y
compris une personne qui est pas qui
n'est pas dans votre territoire comme
son nom l'indiqué ça fait partie des
mesures
importante au delà ça moi je suis très
attaché à mes droits et devoir de
citoyenne on parle de droits de vote
pour moi c'est un devoir le vote et je
suis toujours un peu contrarié quand il
ya des gens qui nous expliquent qu'ils
ont autre chose de plus intéressant à
faire que d'aller voter je crois que
c'est à nous aussi de redonner confiance
dans la démocratie et nous sommes en
train d'y travailler justement les deux
dernières élections ont été marquées par
des abstention record les municipales et
régionales est ce que vous craignez là
aussi pour la présidentielle qui le
rendez vous phare de la politique
française et qui même elle est touchée
par ce phénomène de l'abstention qui
commencent à être touchés parce que là
vous y voyez un risque là aussi parce
qu'il a une valeur une question de
légitimité pour le hula nouveau nul oui
c'est vrai que cette abstention elle
existe et elle est de plus en plus forte
élection après élection
paradoxalement les élections européennes
qui habituellement avait un taux record
d'abstention dans ce quinquennat voulu
immobiliser n'ont même plus me davantage
mobilisés que des élections locales je
crois que il incombera aux candidats et
aux candidates à cette élection de
données de la passion de l'envié et je
crois qu'il nous incombe aussi de
rappeler notamment aux plus jeunes
l'utilité du vote j'ai beaucoup reçu
d'associations de jeunes qui sont très
engagés on peut pas dire que les jeunes
soient pas concernés par la dgi
collective le climat l'égalité
femmes-hommes la cause animale le les
ouïgours il ya énormément de cause qui
mobilise les jeunes dans des
associations mais j'ai le sentiment
qu'il ne se disent pas que cette cause
peut être traduite par le geste d'aller
voter et de choisir un candidat dont je
crois que c'est à nous de faire encore
cette éducation civique si je peux le
dire en tant que maman 7,7 éducation
citoyenne en tout cas elle se rattache
mans la démocratie on va revenir sur
votre déplacement à nice 1 c'était lundi
sur le thème de la sécurité avec cette
annonce notamment aux proches d'une loi
de programmation qui sera présentée en
mars
quel est l'intérêt de présenter cette
loi en mars au moment où le parlement ne
siège plus alors écoutez c'est
effectivement une loi dalo commis une
loi d'orientation et de programmation
sur le ministère de l'intérieur sur les
forces de sécurité intérieure sur la
sécurité l'intérêt c'est qu'en fait pour
nous le travail continue et je sais que
l'opposition reproche parfois au
président la république de travailler
peut-être aimerait-il qui se mettre en
retrait qui est cesse de travailler en
tout cas le réseau politique quand même
c'est dans la continuité du trac nous
avons vous savez moi je suis auprès de
gérald darmanin ministère de l'intérieur
et je vois le ministre de l'intérieur
tous les jours sans discontinuer être au
travail pour réfléchir à la manière
d'améliorer la sécurité des français et
je crois que d'ancêtres l'ogc nice j'en
suis même sûr il ya un certain nombre de
propositions très concrètes quand le
président la république partage pour le
quinquennat suivant absolument mais pour
l'avenir le présent la république il ne
cesse pas s'intéresser au sort des
français au lendemain du 4 ou 10 au
dessus du 24 avril où tout en entraînant
dans les cieux nation ce déplacement les
l'air par la voix de patrick stéphane
guillon nantes annoncé vouloir saisir la
commission des comptes de campagne parce
qu'il considère que c'est un déplacement
de candidat ça va être compliqué jusqu'à
la déclaration de candidature pour
emmanuel macron justement de faire à la
fois du en même temps c'est à dire
continue de présider faire des annonces
et préparer ce qui semble être une
candidature mais vous savez moi je suis
attaché au fait que le présent la
république président et qu'il exerce ses
fonctions il a pas été élu pour quatre
ans et demi et puis pendant six mois on
verra s'il fait campagne il a été élu
pour cinq ans on parlait de la confiance
dans la démocratie le mandat et en vertu
de la constitution de la vème république
un mandat il a une durée il a une date
de début une date de fin nous ne sommes
pas à la date de fin le président la
république exerce ses fonctions et je
vais vous dire si je peux me permettre
j'aimerais que la présidente du conseil
régional ile de france exerce aussi ses
fonctions jusqu'à la fin elle a été élue
elle a gagné l'élection régionale elle a
été élue présidente du conseil régional
d'île de france et bien je souhaiterais
qu'elle puisse exercer ses fonctions il
ya des problèmes en ile-de-france et les
exhorter à 60 ans vous en parlerais pas
cru on parle de valérie pécresse absolue
manifestement elle épargne les barjots
en déplacement en tant que candidate
partout ailleurs qu'en ile de france et
donc moi je me demande qui préside en ce
moment la région ile de france
j'aimerais bien savoir mais il y avait
il y avait ministre vous le savez
marlène schiappa dont vous d'ailleurs
inquiétée en campagne lors des élections
intermédiaires et pourtant vous disiez
que vous exerciez quand même vos
fonctions mines et ça veut dire que
valérie pécresse elle peut pas faire ce
que vous faisiez vous comme vous me
passerais le fait qu être candidate à
l'élection pour devenir présidente de la
république
ça demande pas tout à fait le même nom
de déplacement qu'être candidat doit
être une humble conseillère régionale à
paris l'endroit où je vis et où je
travaille un dernier mot sur un sujet
important puisque vous allez dans
quelques minutes à dijon sur le thème
des violences intra familiales elles ont
augmenté pendant pendant la crise dans
quelle proportion oui pendant
confinement elles ont augmenté alors
après il est toujours difficile de
savoir si ce sont les signalements ou si
ce sont les violences moi je me réjouis
que les signalements augmente vous savez
en cinq ans grâce au quinquennat d'
emmanuel macron grâce au fait que le
présent la république ait voulu faire en
sorte que ce sujet soit la grande cause
de son quinquennat on aura
considérablement libellé coup tu parles
beaucoup de libération de la parole des
femmes moi je trouve que les femmes ont
toujours parlé c'est surtout les coudes
qui s'est libéré et moi il me tient à
coeur de faire en sorte que dans tous
les commissariats dans toutes les
brigades de gendarmerie les plaintes
soient bien prises donc nous avons fait
rire on va là nous avons pris des
mesures pour faire en sorte que ce soit
le cas que 100% nous avons donné des
consignes claires avec gérald darmanin
grâce au grenelle des violences
conjugales et avec edouard philippe nous
avons renforcé la loi nous avons créé
les bracelets anti-rapprochement nous
avons augmenté les téléphones grave
danger nous avons par exemple créé la
saisie des armes des la plainte
aujourd'hui quand une femme va déposer
plainte si elle signale que son
compagnon ou ex-compagnon possède une
arme elle est saisie immédiatement par
les forces de l'ordre mais nous devons
encore aller plus loin par exemple sur
les i scg les intervenantes sociales en
commissariats et gendarmeries nous en
avons recruté 200 le l'objectif c'était
de recruter 80 ans de plus avec le
grenelle des violences conjugales nous
avons dépassé cet objectif il y en a
aujourd'hui 400 dans le pays il ya des
départements qui n'étaient pas couverts
qui aujourd'hui sont couverts grâce au
grenelle des violences conjugales le
président la république nous a demandé
d'aller encore plus loin il a souhaité
qu'on puisse en avoir six ans dans tout
pays je viens en annonce est d'ores et
déjà une nouvelle a dû jouer avec
monsieur le maire de dijon à monsieur
rebsamen merci beaucoup merci à mensah
pas d'avoir été mal un matin
[Musique]